in a town where you're never quite sure
if you're in Mexico the Old West a
down-home US city with classic Americana
feel or just up another coldest sack in
Southern California's endless suburban
sprawl the one thing that seems to unite
everyone is a love of good Mexican food
I'm not just talking about your standard
tacos burritos and chips and salsa in
this town I'm looking for more lay there
are mullahs galore you've heard of
guacamole but there are red Malays black
Malays green mollies there are Malays
with namesakes like the famous mole
poblano from the town of Puebla in
Mexico these are often linked proudly to
someplace a region Oaxaca is the Tierra
de Lucia tamales the land of the seven
mollies but don't forget we're back up
here in San Diego our story starts a few
blocks past this beautiful stretch of
architecture at the city's famous zoo
with this guy I bring him up for two
reasons one
he's a subject of extreme interest to
some members of my travel party and to
his historical territory includes much
of Mexico where he was and even still is
an iconic figure for many traditional
cultures cultures like the Aztecs and
that's where I show you that we're on
this tangent for a reason besides
showing you fuzzy animals because like
the Maya and the Zapotecs Aztec people's
ground up Chili's and other ingredients
and cooked them together to form these
beautiful sauces and they've done this
for hundreds and hundreds of years don't
think that these groups are all just
pre-columbian peoples of ancient Mexico
either the language of the ancient
Aztecs was classical nahuatl and today
there are more than a million speakers
of modern not what that brings us to the
real stuff these savory spicy complex
sauces that's what you're here for right
the Aztec word is moly
the Spanish added some ingredients to
the mix and added their language to the
mix too but sometimes the mixing went
both ways
the Spanish borrowed the word moly
pronounced it male and that's the way it
sounded when these hearty Mexican sauces
made their way to the southwestern
quadrant of these United States where a
lot of people speak English at least in
some towns and some days thanks to all
this history you can scour San Diego for
Malays in English or more less in
Spanish but I don't know how much luck
you'll have speaking Nahuatl around here
you